six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number let's see who
is calling from the five one three area
code caller from five one three go ahead
hey David yeah that's you oh really a
big fan of your show thank you
yeah first I wanted to thank you for
taking a stand against the I guess the
Bernie or bust kind of people mm-hm I
find them to be pretty irritating
because they kind of play the both sides
of the same argument from the left well
to be clear I mean I don't want I want
to make sure if someone doesn't know
what I've said and they just hear you
say that they might like misattribute
certain beliefs to me all I've said is
that as a supporter of Bernie Sanders in
the primary it was very clear to me in
November of 2016 that Hillary Clinton
was the person to vote for that that's
that's what I've said right that's it
and I've also said that the there's no
reason to be skeptical of the Russia
investigation only on the basis of
feeling like it would somehow legitimize
Hillary Clinton like there's some Bernie
Bernie ER Buster's who are afraid of
saying there is merit to the
investigation merely because they think
it would somehow prop up Hillary I just
don't think that's a real concern it's
just that there are two independent
things but okay yes go ahead
okay so I guess my question was I guess
would be pretty simple that would I
could we just go over a quick list of
the impeachable things that was done
okay we've talked about the emoluments
clause for example yes okay I mean did
you want to give me the list first so
the ones that I know over the emoluments
clause you mentioned the presidential
Records Act I think he was reading some
documents that he wasn't supposed to be
right doing and he I think leaked some
classified information to a Russian spy
mm-hmm recruiter yeah I mean listen the
presidential Records Act is not going to
be an impeachable offense whatever
whether you want to make the argument
that it should be or shouldn't be even
the Democratic House and Senate is not
going to impeach Trump for violations of
the presidential Records Act partially
because everybody destroys some records
more than likely it's just the question
of how brazenly you do it the leaking
information
is I believe that it is unquestionably a
national security risk and also really
bad for our alliances to be leaking
information we got from an ally to a
Russian spy recruiter in the Oval Office
but from a legal standpoint the
president unilaterally D classifies
things when he tells them to people that
aren't cleared so that's also not an
impeachable offense I think of what you
listed we're talking about the
emoluments clause if you can make a case
there that would be the impeachable
offense but even beyond that we've got
all sorts of other stuff which could be
impeachable that might surface from the
robert muller investigation the
practical question though is is anybody
actually going to impeach him and if
it's Republicans in the House and Senate
the answer is no hey yeah thank you all
right appreciate the call thank you very
much we are out of time for calls to
everybody that's holding please call in
again we will take calls again next week
and I look forward to hearing from you